today we'd like to discuss tension in a
rope under what conditions is the
tension uniform recall that if we had a
rope and say we were pulling here's our
one end we'll call that
we're pulling at this end with the force
a and we pull on this end B with a force
B that what we meant by tension at any
point in the rope
was that we took an imaginary slice of
the Rope P and we looked at the two
sides and here if we call this the left
side and this the right side then on the
left side we have that the right side of
the Rope is pulling the left side of the
rope by some force F and this is the
left side and the right side is being
pulled by the left side so that's the
right side being pulled by the left side
and what we define the tension at the
point P was to be the magnitude of this
action-reaction pair and that's how we
define tension at a point inside a rope
now we'd like to address the question is
when is the tension under what
conditions can we say that the tension
is uniform which means that at all
points P the tension is the same and in
order to analyze this we'll apply
Newton's second law so let's begin with
the same situation as before let's
consider a rope where we're pulling this
side with a force at the end by the way
we can call this the tension at that end
T of a and on this side we can refer to
this as the tension on side B now
suppose that our mass of the Rope is
nonzero and we now want to apply
Newton's second law but let's also apply
the condition that the acceleration of
the rope is nonzero so you're holding
the rope under some tension by pulling
both sides but the rope is not
accelerating
and so what does that mean when we apply
Newton's second law to the rope well
let's just arbitrarily call that our
positive direction we see by vector
decomposition that we have TB minus ta
equals mass of the rope but because the
acceleration of the rope is zero this
side is zero and we can use Newton's
second law to conclude that the tension
in the rope is uniform when the rope is
not accelerating and this is what we'll
call our case one a zero tension in the
rope is uniform now let's suppose case
two that a is not zero and so now we
have the rope this is point B here's
point a will choose a uniform direction
a and now we can see when we apply F
equals MA that TB minus ta equals mass
of the Rope times the acceleration of
the rope so you're pulling such that TB
is greater than TA by precisely the
quantity M R times a and so the tension
at the ends are not the same and
therefore the tension in the rope is not
uniform now there's a special case here
that we want to consider so even though
a is nonzero let's assume that the mass
of the Rope is very small and this is
often people call this assume the rope
is massless well that's a little strange
we can say the Matt the very very light
string is often the same type of
modeling and under those circumstances
with that assumption you see that there
is no contribution here and with that
assumption that the tension is
approximately uniform ropes are not
massless there's a small difference but
under those circumstances when we say a
very light rope that even if it is
accelerating implies that T is uniform
in the rope and we can say the rope is
under uniform tension and we will often
refer to this case when we analyze
problems where we're pulling objects for
instance in a typical pulley problem